yo if you'd like to support me in this
channel move University in creating more
video tutorials then please consider
making a financial contribution at my
website move University comm thank you
and enjoy the video
okay so enzyme inhibition specifically
competitive inhibitors we talked about
them before but I want to talk about
them more completely here so we know
that a free enzyme and a substrate can
come together to form the enzyme
substrate complex which goes towards
enzyme in products so here I drawn a
free enzyme with an active site sort of
like it with a square shape alright so
this here is the active site and that's
of course where the substrate binds to
give the enzyme substrate complex now
competitive inhibitors they compete with
the substrate for binding at the active
site so we would expect a competitive
inhibitor labeled here as IC I for
inhibitors C for competitive to have a
shape that's similar right so if we put
the substrate as a square the
competitive inhibitor square shaped
would fit into that active site to form
the enzyme inhibitor complex which of
course cannot make product this enzyme
is now inhibited now because the
substrate and the inhibitor both by at
the active site or both try to bind at
the active site the enzyme can only bind
one or the other so the competitive
inhibitor can only bind free enzyme so
let's look at this a little bit
differently so the enzyme can only bind
one of them it can so either the the
enzyme substrate complex will form or
the enzyme competitive inhibitor complex
will form we cannot form an enzyme
substrate inhibitor complex or
competitive inhibitor complex so there's
no ESI not in this case at least because
they can't both bind the active site at
the same time so this enzyme can either
bind the substrate to form the enzyme
substrate complex or the enzyme can bind
the competitive inhibitor to form the
enzyme
if inhibitor complex and of course if
that happens if we have the enzyme bound
by the competitive inhibitor that is the
inhibited enzyme that enzyme cannot give
you product and of course the substrate
cannot bind the enzyme while the
competitive inhibitors is bound that's
an important idea to stress and because
of that because the the substrate can't
bind the enzyme when the inhibitor is
bound what is that due to affinity well
the enzymes affinity for the substrate
well if if the competitive inhibitors
presence makes it so that the substrate
can't bind that must mean that the
enzyme has a reduced affinity and this
actually has an important effect because
that increases the apparent km now what
about v-max though we've talked about
this before about how if you won't maybe
I shouldn't say that because what if you
are only watching this video or not the
other one the idea here is that we could
take substrate and if the concentration
is high enough and they can displace the
competitive inhibitor that's attached to
the enzyme to give you the enzyme
substrate complex that's what this is
here going from substrate knocking off
that competitive inhibitor to form the
enzyme substrate complex this can happen
if there's a lot of substrate if you
imagine this as a sort of game of
musical chairs let's just imagine there
are 10 chairs and there are five maybe
six enzymes and six inhibitors they both
pretty much have an equal chance of you
know sitting down on one of those chairs
which each represent the enzymes active
site but if there are just for the sake
of this example if there are five chairs
five enzymes right five enzyme active
sites and there are a hundred substrates
and only one inhibitor it's much much
much more likely that substrate will sit
in one of those chairs or by one of
those active sites then a competitive
inhibitor will so in essence we can we
could take those substrates displace
these inhibitors and create the enzyme
substrate
complex at the same rate as we would if
this an inhibitor wasn't there that's
again assuming the substrate
concentration is high enough so what
that means is that the v-max can still
be reached because the the enzyme
substrate complex can form and proceed
towards products just as quickly as it
could without this inhibitor if the
substrate concentration is so so high
that it basically negates the effect of
the competitive inhibitor so how does
that look on the hyperbolic graph okay
well in this with this yellow line here
I've drawn the line with no inhibitor in
the pink line with a competitive
inhibitor we're plotting of course
reaction velocity versus substrate
concentration so the yellow line here
reaches a v-max of 100 and of course
these units are concentration units over
time I didn't give specific units in
this case just for the sake of
simplicity so up here this this you know
maximum velocity is V max for the yellow
line and we said that with a competitive
inhibitor we could still reach that
v-max of the concentration of substrate
is high enough so you can probably see
that this this pink line here is sort of
approaching v-max if we increased the
substrate concentration even further
maybe to to a point out here or
something maybe at that substrate
concentration might actually reach the
v-max right so the v-max of this pink
line and the v-max of this yellow line
right with or without an inhibitor these
values of V Max are equal these are
equal values now what if we go to half
the v-max so if we originally had 100
for the v-max if we go down to 50 that's
v-max over to the substrate
concentration at v-max over two is the
km so if we look at the yellow line its
km is the substrate concentration at
half of the v-max which is down here so
this is the km of the uninhibited
reaction of the uninhibited enzyme but
if we notice
for this pink line to get to that same
you know v-max over to right now while
you label that here so this is v-max
over to for both cases to reach that
same v-max over to we need a higher
substrate concentration so this is km of
the inhibited enzyme so sometimes people
call this km apparent and it you can see
that it's larger than the original km
right so this is this km apparent is
larger than that original km now how
does this translate into the
lineweaver-burk plot so what we have
here in orange is the equation you know
the y equals MX MX plus B line for the
lineweaver-burk plot and of course here
is the y intercept which we know is
equal to 1 over the v-max and here we
have X intercepts of these of these two
graphs again yellow no inhibitor pink
with competitive inhibitor so we notice
that the y intercept for both of those
graphs don't you know is the same so it
doesn't change so the yellow one is the
uninhibited reaction and the pink one is
the inhibited reaction but the
y-intercept doesn't change why is that
well the y intercept is equal to one
over the v-max and the v-max did not
change so it makes sense that the y
intercept does not change now the x
intercept did change the original one
here with no inhibitor we'll call that x
intercept one and then over here we've
got x intercept two for the pink
inhibited reaction x intercept two so we
can see that the x intercept one is
further left so and the and the
excellence of two is further right why
is that well the x intercept is equal to
negative 1 over the km and we know the
km change the km increased so x
intercept equals negative 1 over the km
now if km increase that means the x
intercept is going to be smaller if
we're dividing by a bigger km we're
going to have
smaller x-intercept and of course that's
smaller in magnitude right so in terms
of its distance away from zero so here
x-intercept number one let's just say
for the sake of this example and
simplicity sake that this was like
negative five right x-intercept two
since it's closer to zero right closer
to x equals 0 right 0 here closer to
zero zero let's just say that that's
like negative 2 right it's a smaller
magnitude and closer to zero so that
x-intercept is closer to zero a larger
km brings that x-intercept closer to
zero and that of course also has an
effect on the slope the slope is equal
to M which is km over the v-max and we
can see that over here km over v-max so
again the v-max did not change so we can
we get to say that this value you know
just didn't change to same value but the
km increased so we have a bigger number
in the numerator and the same number in
the denominator so what does that do to
our slope we're taking a bigger number
divided by the same small the same v-max
that means our slope is going to
increase right the slope increased which
is why the pink line is at a higher
slope than the original yellow line ok
so I hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching yo if you found that
video helpful then please be sure to
like comment and subscribe for more
content and if you know anybody who
might find this video helpful then
please be sure to share it with them
thank you and happy studying